my name is emily runge and i'm from  newton kansas i graduated newton high  school in 2012 and now i'm a politics  major at hillsdale college this spring  i'm interning at the asian studies  center at heritage foundation in  washington dc for the washington  hillsdale internship program the  washington hillsdale internship program  we call it whip for short we bring  anywhere between 10 to 20 students a  semester out to dc they take two or  three classes and they intern on the  hill at the heritage foundation really  anywhere they want to when we find  somebody coming out of college who has  some practical real world experience  especially experience that applies to  what we do it really sets them apart  washington is one of those places that  kids can learn a lot and gain a lot just  from being here for a few months  in that sense coming here and having  that internship experience i can  guarantee will be  life changing  you